[Musique]
Bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
journal préparé par les équipes de tv78
nous sommes le mardi 21 décembre voici
les titres
celui qui conduit c'est celui qui ne
boit pas à l'approche des fêtes de fin
d'année la sécurité routière se mobilise
notamment contre l'alcool au volant une
nouvelle campagne de sensibilisation et
de prévention et lancer les conseils
pour rester vigilant dans cette édition
les essais en mouvement des rames du
tram 13 ont débuté elles se feront entre
Saint-Cyr-l'École et
Saint-Germain-en-Laye objectif et
l'alimentation électrique pas encore le
système de freinage c'est l'occasion
pour les conducteurs de se former au
pilotage du tram et puis c'est le retour
de Miss et Mister fitness France la
compétition prendra place pour la
première fois dans les Yvelines à
Maurepas quand je suis passionné de
fitness une vingtaine d'athlètes est
attendu pour s'évaluer sur différentes
épreuves
effacer au rebond de l'épidémie
recommandation gouvernementale autour de
la troisième do the le département des
Yvelines a décidé de renforcer son
dispositif vaccinal 3 bus équipe et si
on le département pour proposer des
créneaux aux habitants les vaccine bus
seront présents au moins jusqu'à la fin
du mois de janvier est l'un des
véhicules notamment altière lundi 20
décembre à Montfort-l'Amaury Mélanie
Fauquet se rendre sur place regarder
un peu compliqué pour nous
on vient vers la population et notamment
les populations qui sont les moins
mobile donc en priorité les personnes
âgées qui ne peux pas aller jusqu'à un
centre de vaccination exemple avec la
saturation des centres de vaccination
qui ont été observé ces dernières
semaines on a ouvert la vaccination au
moins de 30 ans en diversifiant notre
proposition on a on a un petit peu de
Pfizer en plus du moderne à pouvoir
répondre aux besoins des des populations
lancer au printemps dernier cette
nouvelle campagne a débuté dans des
villes identifié par la ras le
département c'est ensuite rapprocher des
communes non rattaché à des centres de
vaccination 35 bénéficier de ses
services cela fait un certain temps
quand même que nous avons été sollicités
et pour la troisième injection de la
part de Montfort foie et aux alentours
devant une telle difficulté pour obtenir
des rendez-vous notamment au centre des
nous avons contacté le département avec
qui nous en plus mettre en place cette
expérience de Maximus que nous avions
déjà vécu dans passé lui personne du
conseil départemental se déplace avec
l'ensemble du matériel jusqu'à 200
patients poste être vacciné par jour les
bus seront à Élancourt le 22 décembre à
plaisir le 23
je vous le disais en titre et à
l'approche des fêtes de fin d'année la
sécurité routière se mobilise pour avec
de nouveaux clips de sensibilisation
notamment contre l'alcool au volant et
on fait le point avec vous aujourd'hui
avec Marie Gauthier mes rêves on soir
Bonsoir je le rappelle en vous êtes
délégué interministériel à la sécurité
routière est-ce que les fêtes de fin
d'année finalement sont plus favorables
aux accidents vous avez des chiffres ou
des des choses à nous donner là-dessus
l'alcool est présent dans un tiers des
accidents mortels en France est présent
dans la moitié des accidents qu'on lieu
la nuit donc on voit que c'est quelque
chose qui est souvent lié à une
consommation festive notamment en fin de
semaine et au moment des fêtes donc
c'est vrai que ces périodes de fin
d'année dans lequel nous allons je
l'espère tous passé de bons moments et
des moments qui parfois sa compagne de
consommation d'alcool et bien sont des
occasions et là ce propice à ce type
d'accident TNT est-ce que les les
contrôles sont renforcés pendant cette
période
oui souvent il y a effectivement
certains de contrôles qui sont organisés
mais sans attendre les contrôles il nous
appartient à tous les biens de faire en
sorte de ne pas prendre le volant
lorsque nous avons trop bu
quand on tient à quelqu'un on le retient
il y a de nouveau spot qui sont sortis
des spots de sensibilisation qui sont
visibles depuis à la mi-décembre je vous
repose déjà de découvrir le clip et on
en parle juste après
qu'est-ce que vous dites vous a
quelqu'un qui a trop bu pour l'empêcher
de partir à l'aventure s'arrête pour toi
donc on a compris on disait c'est un
petit surtout dirigée contre l'alcool au
volant on voit un peu des personnalités
françaises face au fait d'année au fin
de fin d'année qui arrive avec les fêtes
surtout ce n'est pas que j'aime c'est
plutôt positif positif comment on fait
justement pour arriver à sensibiliser à
toucher les gens
alors le mode hors effectivement sur
cette période de fin d'année c'est
souvent quand on tient à quelqu'un on le
retient parce que l'alcool a ceci de
particulier que l'on mésestime soi-même
les dangers que l'on pour au fond plus
on a bu moins on est apte à mesure et
qu'on est pas en capacité de conduire
Douai s'il important de le faire avec
les autres et de compter sur l'entourage
pour aussi vous retenir l'objectif était
évidemment de se mettre un peu au
diapason de la période de fêtes l'idée
n'est pas de viens de dire aux gens
qu'il faut pas profiter de ces moments
de fête mais de se dire que pour que la
fête dure longtemps et qu'elle soit
belle jusqu'au bout c'est important
d'être très responsable tous ensemble
notamment sur la question de l'alcool au
volant
justement vous parliez de l'entourage
selon vous un rôle essentiel
oui bien sûr je voulais dire en
particulier pour l'alcool parce que il y
a une en fait loin de sur confiance en
soi qui arrive avec une consommation
excessive d'alcool donc parfois on ne se
rend pas compte soi-même qu'en fait on
n'est plus du tout on n'est pas conduire
donc c'est important aussi que les
autres vous offre un reflet de cette
situation c'est important aussi et bien
d'anticiper de préparer la fête en
intégrant cette dimension là et on
réfléchit sans est bien au fait de
pouvoir garder à dormir ce qui ne
peuvent pas reprendre le volant où est
bien de mettre des éthylotests à la
disposition de ses invités pour essayer
d'objectiver un peu la consommation
d'alcool de chacun
alors justement il y a des astuces vous
avez parlé notamment de l'éthylotest
pour rester vigilant par exemple une
personne en début en début de soirée
quels sont les conseils justement autres
qu'on peut appliquer qui sont assez
facile à appliquer pour éviter et rester
vigilant
je vais vous donner des conseils qui
seront moins expliqué avec moins
d'humour que ceux de l'image et de la
message que vous venez de passer qui
sont les mots des animateurs télé et de
Fred Testot qu'ils ont fait avec avec
pas mal de pas mal d'humour
donc je vais être un peu plus triste
mais effectivement encore une fois
l'idée c'est d'anticiper de s'organiser
on peut prévoir par exemple une boîte à
clés en arrivant et puis on on
souffle dans un ethylotest et qui
effectivement
il y a aussi effectivement
mais cette fois-ci
[Musique]
rester vigilant s'amuser mais en tout
cas à prendre ses précautions merci
beaucoup Marie Gauthier malgré d'avoir
été avec nous je la rappelle à vous êtes
bien évidemment délégué interministériel
à la sécurité routière merci beaucoup
c'est la dernière étape avant la marche
à blonde Eram du tram 13 Île-de-France
mobilité lance ce mardi 21 décembre ses
premiers essais sur la nouvelle ligne de
tramway est-ce qu'il y a entre
Saint-Cyr-l'École et
Saint-Germain-en-Laye objectif tester
l'alimentation électrique le système de
freinage encore la signalisation
lumineuse CDC se dérouleront jusqu'au
printemps avant une répétition générale
et mise en service à l'été 2022 va-t-il
de Franck où est Nicolas dans tes
[Musique]
sur la partie historique entre
arctique avant snap la Grande Ceinture
entre Saint-Cyr et
c'est comme un train ça veut dire que
les stations sont un peu plus espacées
est la vitesse maximum est plus
importante
aller jusqu'à 100 km heure sur la partie
urbaine la vitesse moins importante
puisque on est sur la voirie le tram
et donc là on est parti en plastique
comme un tramway
on va commencer à tester
la signalisation
le collège cheveux par son père pour le
tram il était au travail
et puis la puissance électrique il faut
que la puissance pour accélérer
un gros travail au niveau des
sous-stations électrique pour vérifier
que les sous-station électrique
fonctionne bien et au moment la bonne
puissance électrique
on va commencer la marche à blanc blanc
l'opérateur de transport
qui vont commencer à
travailler sur la ligne à blanc comme si
c'était normal mais sans les voyageurs
ça c'est utile formé tous les écouteurs
et puis tous les personnels au centre de
contrôle et au centre de maintenance que
les personnels commence à maintenir les
hommes et les infrastructures comment
situation réelle
après une édition annuler en 2021 c'est
le retour de Miss et Mister à fitness
France la compétition et cette année
organisé au CdCl Center à Maurepas une
vingtaine d'athlètes est attendu pour
s'évaluer sur différentes épreuves
Michael et 1000 €
de l'écharpe à l'organisation qui a dit
bah vas-y repère une dernière fois les
locaux du SDIS Center à Maurepas le 29
décembre prochain 20 à transpirer pour
devenir Miss et Mister fitness France
2022 compétition et pas un concours
c'est très important en fait une
compétition tout simplement parce que
tous ceux qui est évalué ce jour-là
c'est la performance donc c'est le
maximum qu'on est capable de faire la la
résistance qu'on a à la force qu'on a
le courage et la détermination à faire
des épreuves et non pas non pas le
physique qui est pris en compte une
partie des 1000 mètres carrés du
complexe sportif sera dédié à la
compétition venu de toute la France les
concurrents sont attendus sur plusieurs
des preuves que je pratique en salle ou
seulement passionné de fitness leur
profil sont nombreux il faut avoir la
capacité à faire déjà des tractions ça
c'est super important des pompes être
bon au poids de corps et surtout il faut
avoir un profil complet il faut être
aussi bon en exercice cardio-vasculaire
quand musculation c'est la première fois
que la compétition est organisée dans
les Yvelines les places sont disponibles
sur la page Facebook de l'organisation
dans l'attente de l'évolution sanitaire
et puis côté environnement et
biodiversité Yann Arthus-Bertrand viens
d'acquérir un terrain de 28 hectares au
moins au Mesnil dans les Yvelines une
information révélé par nos confrères du
parisien situé dans la vallée de La
Minière il soit en faire une réserve
naturelle objectifs du célèbre
photographe français préserver les
quelques 400 espèces animales et
végétales à vivre sur place et ouvrir le
site au public le projet pour avoir le
jour en 2023
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à tous
de nous avoir suivi très bonne soirée
sur TV 78 et surtout prenez soin de vous
[Musique]